32 ai que medo de quem fala é o dark
sejam muito bem vindos
a mãe dela eu os trato de que mais um
vídeo de microscópio é pop sempre muito
receptivo o episódio observar em insetos
com um microscópio paraná enquanto
conforme ontem aos 32 um carro muito bom
10 mil likes
portanto vamos tentar atingir essa meta
pessoal vamos tentar atingir os 30 dias
que eu vou tentar observar coisas ainda
mais nojentas mas eu vou tentar ver
sangue eu vou tentar ver o esperma como
já tinha dito antes obviamente foi
animal é porque não vai ser o meu não eu
vou tentar de algum tipo tentar ver as
coisas
o episódio vai ser só em sétimo tento
deixou 300.000 ix vamos lá só se faz com
a entrega e para lá boa melhora e não só
tem aqui um microscópio pronto tenho
sete pronto e eu tive que estas semanas
a tentar apanhar os utentes mote à
campanha alguns latina pane alguns
atrasos no jardim eu acho que consegui
um sem-teto não vai começar só pelo
bicho em conta porque o tubo é curioso
porque eu tenho vai patas
então vamos lá ver um trauma nas costas
e morreu
a partir de agora 30 mai amarelo que
banha
amarrar as patas ver uma coisa que vocês
não sabem nem eu sabia é este o
microscópio ainda dar mais um eu pensava
que estava usado em eventos mas não
estava 40 vezes como podem ver e quinho
40 vezes não tenho nenhum vestígio não
rodava isso que eu pensava que sair do
foco mas afinal ainda tem mais um para
além daquilo que já usávamos vai contar
com 11 mil vezes lá ok ele supostamente
ter 40 anos e agora aproximar olha só a
aproximar o movimento está tudo claro
mas já vai ficar
olha só os 1 mil e ainda não é mais só
isso aqui é uma tinha única do visto
contas brutal ganha ou empata em pêlo
não querem mais nada no próximo se
expandiram em que eu gosto muito que eu
escreva ituiutaba indústria vem já o leu
e com rosto em uma mistura de várias
coisas e aí nós vamos ver 32 pmas ernani
lo ou eu nem sei o que eu tô gestão rabo
de um aparelho que tem umas manchas de
cor castanho e que já é meio preto é um
parceiro do buraco em todo o corpo
tem muito poder mais teia da aranha meu
descuido do norte e coreia do sul
eu não tenho olho roxo aí é fazê la
porta del este trabalho é muito grande
por isso não dá pra ver vai mas vou
tentar vingá lo ao contrário vamos ver
na barriga eu tem muita textura textura
de barriga seu erro acho que ele
entendeu que encontra aí eu acho que tem
cabeça depois comentem o que vocês acham
quatro do corpo escreveu nesta é cabeça
é o rap eu não faço idéia é muito
estranho e tem idéias legal e tem muita
saída eu acho que todos estes animais é
dar uma porrada com uma aranha com
certeza o crédito ao próximo inseto
então vai ser a nossa música que mantém
onde estava a lancha 21 vai nu ou núcleo
de texto é o animal mais bonito que eu
vi o microscópio movimento suave com 45
é muito lindo
aqui o time na barriga
veja só textura da casa dela pessoal é
muito lindo aqui já no cocó já teve no
qual posso jogar pelo resolver disse
com vários tons de azul que não é muito
nojento ela tem um bonecão enorme você
tá pelo contrário agora tinha muito dela
a voz dela uma coisa que eu sempre achei
interessante é muita música e não só
fechado mas sim a música tem vários
olhos dentro do ônibus
a única lei que dão lugar às 11 horas só
isto é a cabeça da música dela mas vamos
passar ao próximo inseto o próximo
técnico vai ter uma aranha e ficaram em
106 não é um teto não só é muito nem
conseguem melhor proveito do talento de
aprender muita coisa souto nem o meu eu
juruá
e nós temos vídeos mil e diga com a
cinta button eu ela tem vários tipos de
pneu tem um preto tem pelo corpo
o véu em um olho dela não é que o o
ônibus tem muitos olhos em um dois três
quatro cinco
mesmo perto da nossa escala meu bicho
não é bem um inseto que é estranha
dentro da casa
ei louco total é muito louca porque ela
tem 32 e focada
[Música]
dura a escala do formiga elas devem ser
muito forte e antenas ela a líbia
importa tomar sol e tinham suas garras
dela vejam só o pêlo
ela tem muito tempo num rabo próxima e
sexual vai ser um evento muito especial
e um esquisito este mosquito está
literalmente enrolado em teia de aranha
mas não só eu fui encontrar numa teia de
aranha e não está totalmente coberto do
time expôs também aranha já tinha comido
já susan e que te deu e dá aqui só para
passar meu brutal 321 mais fui
já comecei por ver a equipe bateu com
muito pêlo mais uma vez suas teias
pátria está enrolada natureza
aqui você já consegue ver muito bem
estranhas disse que o tórax da equipa às
costas nem olho e vai ser um ano de
gancho e wii
vou tentar ficar vou ficar olhando eo
enorme mais uma textura do olho é muito
igual a música e para encararem é tocou
eu tenho um leque enorme eu acho que o
estúdio também por dentro não apresenta
mais próximo e um centro vai ser a nossa
amiga era só que é uma aranha especial
porque ela é muito grande mesmo não é
assim tão grande mas é maior do que o
outro 32
ae
como assim ganha muito maior muito mais
gorda mas pude me reúno as duas gigantes
do pêlo é muito perto uma bola na boca
do túnel isso tudo é um ovo
vestidos a idéia é o que vamos ou não
vamos ficar porque os filhos para fazer
tenham gostado já sabem vão tentar
atingir a meta dos 300 mil likes neste
vídeo exatamente que deram uma parte
2007 por manchetes que eu não vi o zico
não os encontrei morte mas se quiserem
ver uma segunda parte comenta e também
que os vossos lábios a 3 manter o vírus
provavelmente não viram e embaixo mas
podem sofrer aqui no canal do dado que
já estava em fique bem e da próxima